free Hands-On robotic training for
teachers even those soon-to-be teachers
that's right they're building their
skills to educate the future about
robots Lauren negretti live this morning
at the desert Research Institute near
UNLV to test the Bots herself Lauren
good morning
good morning beep beep hello yes we are
here at Desert Research Institute to
talk about a bot boot camp training
teachers how to use robots in the
classroom now they're going to be three
summer sessions Las Vegas Elko and Reno
to talk more about it I'm joined by AJ
long here with desert Research Institute
so AJ what is the benefit of teaching
Educators how to use robots in the
classroom these are truly Workforce
Development skills and our goal is to
build confidence in teachers so that
they can bring robotics computer science
and coding to their students as early as
Pre-K all the way through 12th grade and
we had some fun this morning here you
say early as Pre-K we've got ones that
are just a touch to code beep beep so
you basically just touch the robot tell
it what to do
and then they crash into each other for
fun and then they fight to the death of
robots uh there's also some like drag
and drop as well so you know um what
would you say this really gives as far
as you know the students a chance to
learn too we're really trying to
increase Equity diversity and get more
girls in computer science and
engineering and so this allows them to
have exposure early on
tonight come join us at the desert
Research Institute from 4 to 7 30 we
have Hands-On science and and introduce
introduction to dri perfect thank you
yes may the fourth be with you today
well like we said you could catch more
of this information and sign up at
Nevada
robotics.org for now live at the desert
Research Institute Laura negretti 8 news
now back to you guys all right Lauren
thank you very much very cool stuff I
love it